The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Museum of Holography.
Well everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of Holo Talk for the week of April 5th, 1999.
My guest this week is Alan Rohdy from Ross Books.
And Alan is going to come on the show to tell listeners about the release of their eighth edition of the holography marketplace, which is the uh reference guide for those working in the field of holography and those who also need to get more information about those working in the field of holography.
What's special about this eighth edition is that it contains a full color photopolymer hologram on its cover, manufactured by Dynapan in Japan.
And this is the first publication in the world to have a color hologram on its cover.
And it makes it basically a collector's item for this eighth edition.
The holography marketplace is uh quite a bit more than just a listing of who is working in the field of holography contained within its cover.
You can also find information on what holograms are, how holograms are made, the different types of holograms and uh how they differ from one another, the different types of lasers that are used to make holograms, and a lot of other technical information also especially for this issue, a lot of technical information on the new emulsions such as those from uh uh BB plates uh from Germany and Slavage Materials, uh a lot of technical specifications on those as well.
So it's really a working guide for a lot of people that are working in the field of holography as well.
It's a very valuable tool for the art world uh for art directors and different people who are working in the creative fields who someday may have to make specifications or specify a job that will contain a hologram, and it gives them a lot of background information so they can make intelligent decisions and intelligent choices as to what a hologram is capable of doing and also what it's not capable of doing.
And it gets them right in the ball game very quickly.
So it's a it's a great publication.
I look forward to receiving it all the time.
And I think I may even be one of the first people to call because I know as soon as I get the announcement in the mail, I walk right over to the phone and call and order my copy, and I can read that copy from cover to cover.
In this studio, here in my studio in Allentown, Pennsylvania, we were able to make a hologram using one of the higher power diodes, higher power being relatively speaking compared to the laser pointers.
We used a 15 milliwatt, 635 nanometer uh semiconductor diode to create a hologram here.
It was a very good test.
I do have some photos and some um information up on the web already.
So if you go to my laser pointer part of my website, you'll be able to see the latest report on using this diode.
And this is very exciting because it's uh moving us into a higher powers, and I'm looking forward to continuing uh to do experiments to see how high we can go.
Can we go up into the 30 milliwatt range?
Can we go into the half watt 500 milliwatt range and uh have very high power uh diodes creating holograms?
So we'll get back on that next week and we'll concentrate on the uh the interview with Alan Rhode this week.
So I'm not going to come back on after the interview is over, so I will say thank you for tuning in now.
And I hope you tune in each and every week to HoloTalk to get news and information and guests and interviews uh for the field of lasers and holography.
And um after this message, we will be right back with the interview with Alan Rhody from Lost Books.
Thanks for tuning in.
See you next week.
Would you like to make your own one of a kind hologram and learn how you can start making holograms on your own at the same time?
You can do this and much more by attending one of Frank Defradis' holography workshops.
From beginner to advance, Frank's got a workshop that's just right for you.
From single afternoon, evening, or weekend introductory workshops to Wednesday evening five-week complete courses.
And don't forget his newest workshop, Laser Pointer Holography.
Located just off the northeast extension of the Pennsylvania Turnpike and Interstate 78.
The studio is a quick non-stop drive from the New York, Philadelphia, and Baltimore, Washington, D.C.
areas.
For more information, call the studio's toll-free hotline at 1-800-458-3525 and begin your own journey with holography today.
That's 1-800-458-3525.
For more information on attending a Frank Defratus holography workshop today.
Alan, it's Frank Defratus.
How are you?
Hi, Frank.
I'm just fine.
Uh, I gave you a call so that the uh HoloTalk listeners can get an update on your latest eighth edition of the holography marketplace.
Fantastic.
And it's that time again.
It's always a welcome sight to see the holography marketplace arrive in the mail.
Thank you.
We got a good one this year.
Oh, you certainly do.
Why don't why don't we start off with probably the biggest news?
Of course, that's for you to decide what the biggest news or not, but the biggest news to me was that cover.
The cover hologram uh represents I think the first true color, or which is full color, uh mass produced hologram that um is produced on photopolymer, a very practical plastic material uh practical to use and um it was produced by Dinipon, uh the largest printing company in Japan on a DuPont material, DuPont Photopolymer.
Uh they call it a true color material because every color can be replicated realistically.
Mm-hmm.
In the samples they sent us originally.
They had blacks, they had whites, um, the full colors uh hard colors to reproduce like brown.
So it's pretty remarkable technology.
They're the first ones really to put it out.
And I was surprised to see the whole process plain right in the marketplace itself.
Yeah, uh pretty much most of it.
We got in touch with the guys that uh actually make 'em.
They um Dinnippon has been working with DuPunk over ten years because Dynipon also makes embossed holograms, and they've had a good working relationship, but they were the first company really to put together the lasers, the replicator.
Um other people have made full collar holograms, other people have uh experimented with them a little on the full color material, but this is the first uh uh commercial mass production.
Uh they did a job of uh trading cards in Japan, some astro boid trading cards.
They sent us some samples that were relatively large compared to all the other photopolymer uh samples out there.
It was a five inch by seven inch scene and we cut it in half for the cover of the book of Parrots in a jungle and you can see the parrots have, you know, red, blue, green, yellow.
Um they're sitting on brown branches and the image appears to be about three three ish inches deep.
Um it's nice and clear, it's nice and bright.
It's uh viewable in a wide variety of lighting conditions.
Yeah, good lighting, it you know it appears the best, but it has a lot of commercial applications.
I found that the image actually exceeds the thickness of the book.
Yeah, that's pretty easy.
Right through the book.
Now for listeners who may be logging on that may not be familiar with the holography marketplace, why don't you just take a few moments to explain in general what it is and what it's about.
Uh Ross Books started publishing holography related materials back in nineteen eighty two when they brought out the holography handbook.
And there wasn't much of a holography industry back then.
What existed was really the retail marketplace for holographic art and giftware.
Uh commercially it started being used a lot in the mid eighties when um manufacturers figured out how to hot stamp one type of hologram embossed foils onto paper and cardboard.
So the industry developed and we started tracking the industry in eight nineteen eighty nine with a book called the holography marketplace which is a business directory that's updated regularly and text and reference material and then what makes the book extra unique is the manufacturers put holograms in the book so it acts like a sample kit for people that either collect holograms or want to see what the manufacturers have to offer what's available to them to actually purchase.
Some people might look at the book and say, yeah, I want a hologram like on page seventeen.
Other people, no, I like this kind that's on page, you know, twenty seven.
Uh so the book is now coming out annually.
It's about two hundred and fifty pages, twenty two ninety five, ship it anywhere in the world, um for additional, you know, UPS or postal charge.
And um it's got twenty holograms in it.
This year, each year we feature a new state of the art hologram on the cover.
It represents um what's either coming right out of the research labs or available in the uh top manufacturers.
You couldn't buy those holograms for twenty probably just one of those holograms would cost more than twenty two million.
Yeah, the one on the cover this year, you know, we in the if it was available, if it was invented, you know, way back when it'd probably be about a seventy dollar hologram.
Yeah.
Uh matted and framed up, which we encourage people to do, buy two on the bookshelf.
Hey I've been thinking about that.
Very far enough yourself.
It's gonna be a real collector's item because i it's analogous to the first color photograph that's out.
And you know, i I'm sure in ten years these will be commonplace and there are a couple companies in the United States you know working with DuPont to start production.
Uh since the stuff is so rare and only a few people can do it, the natural uh commercial application is security.
Because anytime only one factory can make something it makes it, you know, hey, hard to copy.
So in DuPont and a couple of manufacturers want to use this material for security purposes, but at least the Japanese and one or two other companies are either doing you know ongoing research or trying to start commercial display applications of signage or maybe replicating artwork or in this case doing everything from trading cards to um uh you know at point of purchase displays premiums that sort of thing.
Yeah.
So right now there's really only one plant in commercial production in the world and that is uh Dinepan of Japan.
Now if you're listening to the show I want you to grab pencil and paper because I'm going to ask Alan in just a few moments to give the contact information on ordering your own copy of holography marketplace.
So you might want to reach into the desk or wherever you happen to have your pencil and paper uh stored and get that and get that ready so you can write this down and we'll also have a link right to the Ross Books website.
Now if you're listening to this and you think that uh you're an amateur or hobby stillographer or something like that and and you're not really interested in what other companies are working with holography, the holography marketplace is actually a whole lot more than that from what I was able to sit down and read so far and I do read every issue of these from cover to cover, even the listings, every page you have a lot of information in there on what holograms are, how lasers work.
I mean it's almost like an instruction guide, right?
Well yes, because it's meant to it's it's primarily meant for the intelligent business person that wants to use holography but might only know what he's heard in the movies.
So it starts off very basic every chapter starts off very basic.
We break it into the basics, an introduction to holography, you know, what it's all about, how you can use them, how many of them are around in the world today, and then if you want to make them yourself, you know, the basic theory behind 'em.
And then as the chapters go on, um it gets more in depth uh materials and the lasers and um commercial applications.
But each chapter, you know, we actually intend it uh consciously to start.
Um yeah, anybody can understand it.
Yeah, a couple of formulas and things are thrown in at at the end for the people that need that too.
Yeah.
I found it very valuable to have a comprehensive listing of all the technical specifications for the new emotions, which are really hard to find.
Right, the guys that are making holograms on a day to day basis will appreciate the book.
And then again for the person that's just starting out or just the artist, uh the designer who's never gonna make a hologram but might have to design one.
Or their company, you know, president comes in the door, hey what's w what's going on?
How can we use these?
And they have to come up with some answers.
They might not actually be in the lab making them, but we have to give them some information they can use too.
A lot of um holograms now are being made with video footage and computer footage and digital data that people have around and um this the there's a chapter that says oh how you can integrate that and make a hologram out of that.
Yeah it's it's probably really important for art directors and people who are working on the uh creative end of it to understand what this process is like.
I get emails all the time.
A few weeks ago I got an email from a guy asking would it be possible to make a holographic parade float and uh how the uh would it be able to be used in the daytime or could uh the street lights illuminate the parade float as it came down the street and that'd be great.
Yeah it would be great but it's a wild idea.
I mean we're not gonna we're not gonna see any holographic parade floats coming down the street.
Not for off.
But a book yeah.
A book like this not until about ten o'clock tonight.
A book like this would give artists, uh art directors and some of the other people working in uh uh production studios an opportunity to see what holography is capable of doing and also what it's not capable of doing because it's not capable of doing a lot of the things that people think that it can.
Absolutely.
We have that in a chapter two.
We actually do have an article in there this year about the myths of holography, uh written by a guy that makes holograms for display and exhibition um every day.
So uh yeah, there's some good information in there.
Are the listings up or down as far as people working in the field of philography for this?
Um, listings are up.
It's spreading out well, we're also reaching um many more people through the internet.
Mm-hmm.
So it's probably a combination of there's more businesses, more specialized businesses, and we're just hitting uh a lot more people that we couldn't several years ago on, you know, 'cause it was just fax machines.
Yeah.
And now, you know, we can put on an internet uh search and uh we get emails every day from all across the world.
We send the book out all over the world.
Yeah.
How about if you give people information on uh how they can order the holography marketplace from you?
And like I said, we'll also have a link to your website.
They can order it also from the web.
Exactly.
Um the easiest way to get a hold of us, um, since you're at your computer is email.
Uh we're at uh sales at Rolfsbooks dot com.
And our website is W W Ross R O S S books dot com.
Roth's books, all one word, that's the name of our company.
And uh by phone, you can get a hold of us if you're in the US.
Uh one eight hundred three six seven zero nine three zero international is five one zero eight four one two four seven four and the old fashioned facts machine five one zero eight four one two six nine five and our address is Ross Books R O S Set the WordBooks.
PO box four three four zero Berkeley, California nine four seven zero four.
There you go now always here.
Your first your first issue of this is a collector's item now.
Five hundred bucks.
Yeah.
Uh we didn't realize that there's a there's a a book collector's market but you don't really even care that it's a holography book.
But since it can never be reprinted because these holograms will never be made again, uh it's a very valuable in that there is a it's a limited edition.
Yeah.
And now they're the book collectors learning all about holography.
So uh yeah, keep 'em all.
We we're actually selling the back editions too for a very nice price and uh put the kids through college one day off them.
Yeah it's also a great historical uh record of holography in the field as well those collections.
Exactly.
There's some pioneers in there.
Well Alan I want to thank you for being a guest and taking the time to come on a few minutes to uh talk with us about this latest eighth edition of the holography marketplace and uh wish you good luck with it this time around just as you've had in the past with the other editions as well.
My pleasure.
Last thing I want to say is just keep visiting the Holo World website.
Thank you.
That's a great one.
Okay.
Okay, bye bye